pour une troisième nuit constitutive de
petit groupe de manifestants ont brûlé
des poubelles et des voitures
et 9 août il se pose au passeport
sanitaire et à la vaccination
obligatoire des travailleurs de la santé
imposée par le gouvernement français
depuis le 15 novembre une approche avec
des relents colonialistes selon eux
nommés aux autres voilà on a
l'impression d'être déchu de la
métropole et ça suffit
aussitôt ou nettoyer de nouvelles
barricades sont érigées
se faufiler entre deux carcasses de
voitures calcinées fait maintenant
partie du quotidien pour moi c'est une
éponge au pouvoir c'est à dire
on fait pas une gueule comme ça
plusieurs magasins ont été vandalisés et
pillés dont ce supermarché
ils ont tiré en plein été au niveau du
magasin donc non plus un peu de la
viande un peu de tout ils ont fait des
courses 3 en vente conséquence
l'approvisionnement en nourriture et en
essence paralyse la guadeloupe
destination normalement prisé par de
nombreux voyageurs comme raconte cette
franco québécois sur place
pour justement ramener une amy québécois
ce qui avait sans mal à four moyen et on
a été bloqué
par des manifestants cagoulés
un mouvement qui prend ces assises chez
une partie du personnel soignant
suspendu parce qu'il refuse d'être
vaccinés si vous permettez c'est le
choix et qu'on respecte mon choix et
auprès de ceux qui réclament une plus
grande attention à la jeunesse
l'éducation et aux infrastructures de
première nécessité l'accès à l'eau
potable c'est un droit
dans un pays où le tiers de la
population vit encore sous le seuil de
la pauvreté la violence n'a pas sa place
sur le territoire de la république en
guadeloupe comme ailleurs la france de
ramener l'ordre dans son territoire
outre mer
de 150 policiers et gendarmes dont 50
des forces spéciales du gipn et du raid
ont été envoyés en renfort
bref une colère qui s'étend en
martinique où si ici gabriel proulx
radio canada montréal